I had just turned 13 when the first
Harry Potter movie came out.
According to Warner brothers,
nearly 60 percent of the people who saw
that movie were 17 or younger.
For a whole general,
the Harry Potter series spanned are
adolescents and imprinted onto our
lives.
A love of reading,
but less has been said about the films.
I think their commitment to good
cinematic work was potentially just as
important for young people's filmic
education as j Dot k dot rowling's
accomplishments were for our literary
upwork.
For me,
that all starts with Alfonzo,
Koran,
and the third film in the series,
the prisoner of Azkaban coming at a
crucial time in both the books and the
films.
Azkaban marks.
Potters transitioned from perilous
adventure stories for children to
increasingly dark increasingly nuanced
treatments of character and plot.
Pick,
inquire,
Ron,
to handle this passage seems perfect in
retrospect as it set the tone for the
grimmer and grimy or final installment
of the series,
but warner brothers has to be credited
for taking a chance on a director whose
previous film was an explicit Mexican
road trip,
drove about sexual discovery.
A lot of the style of that film and
Korans previous work is readily apparent
in Azkaban,
most notably his fondness for a moving
often handheld camera.
Just take a quick sped up.
Look at this early scene from the Great
Hall,
not a single shot is stationary.
This gives the scene and the film a
feeling of forward momentum and
establishes a curious camera,
but it also lends to the film a sense of
unease and inability to find stable
footing.
Now for a film that is to be haunted by
a feared killer throughout such a style
is fitting and this isn't the only
signature technique Koran brings to
potter is famous use of the long tail is
here as well.
The shot right here is a minute and 49
seconds long,
and as the critic Kristen Thompson has
noted,
it marks a crucial tonal shift in the
film.
The first two scenes,
one in which Harry blows up,
his horrible aunt and one which he takes
a ride on.
The ridiculous night busts are both
pretty lighthearted.
Good.
Almost say that these two scenes are a
nod to the two comparatively lighter
films that came before this in this
scene and this shot Harry learns of the
true danger he faces than what's
important to notice here is that with
deeper,
more significant peril comes deeper,
more significant isolation Mr Weasley
pulls Harry into another part of the
leaky cauldron,
separating him from his friends while
keeping the specter of Sirius black in
the foreground.
When the conversation turns explicitly
to black,
is images placed between them with
family and friends framed in the
background.
Then Mr Risley pulls Harry into an
alcove so that they are alone,
asking Harry not to go looking for
black.
And finally for the key dramatic
question and period on the scene.
Well Ron Frames Harry completely by
himself.
Now,
this is great film.
Isolation will go on to be a key theme
in Asca Pan and the rest of the series,
despite its constant message of
friendship and it's focus on the bond
between Harry Ron and her mining.
The series returns with Ridley to
Harry's,
feelings of being alone.
The chosen one is gradual realization of
a burden that he must carry without
help.
Prisoner of Azkaban reflects,
deepens and foreshadows these feelings
by separating Harry out from his
surroundings or else placing him apart
from those around him.
Koran never misses a chance to return to
this theme,
whether it means separating Harry from
his friends in a shot about something
else,
telling Emma Watson to neal out of a
shot or ending the movie by having Harry
literally fly away from a crowd.
Internal consistency.
This is one of Koran's major strengths.
That's what makes the prisoner of
Azkaban a cut above the rest of the
films in the series,
some of which are quite good motifs
shoot back and forth across the runtime
like magic spells and comment on each
other,
tightening a web that leases meaning
throughout little things like following
empty footsteps in the snow before
introducing a key object that visualizes
people moving through hogwarts castle
with footsteps.
Some immediate foreshadowing there,
but what about some longer
foreshadowing?
Maybe a little bird that flies around
the grounds in the beginning of the film
to places will only later occur to us
that map the sites of significant scenes
in the movie,
or what about something more meaningful
like Korans recurring motif of moving
the camera through glass,
a Motif that pays off twice in this
scene where the students fight off of
Bulger,
a creature that visualizes your worst
fear twice in this seat into beautiful
shots.
The camera moves through the mirrors.
Have this wardrobe suggesting that while
it's important to look through windows
and see the world,
you can also look through mirrors,
which is to say into yourself.
Not to mention that these shots just
make you think,
wait,
how did he do that?
A great question for any young film goer
to ask,
and that's the point here,
isn't it?
We hear so much about a film industry
that continues to pump out crap films
that's ruled by lowest common
denominator fair.
Oh,
there are a number of reasons for that,
but one of them is that a lot of the
movie going public suffers from
cinematic illiteracy.
We don't know what makes a good film,
so the industry serves up superficial
projects that play on cheap emotions and
make us into passive viewers,
but learning film is always an active
enterprise.
All great movies are teaching movies
because they encourage us to participate
with them and with the whole of cinema.
This is why the prisoner of Azkaban is
so important,
like anything,
it's easy to develop a taste for
something when we learn it.
Young.
Harry Potter is a mega franchise.
One,
millions of kids bought tickets for and
millions more will watch and rewatch at
home.
Having a great film like this in that
roster.
Well,
the results could be exponential.
Small light that in the end shines much
brighter than anyone would expect.
Hey,
thanks for watching.
Obviously I'm a huge Harry Potter Fan.
I grew up with those books,
those ages at the beginning.
We're actually my ages,
so this was a blast to make.
I want to thank you guys actually
because a lot of people actually pledged
a dollar or $3 after last week's video
and those small pledges really mean so
much because what matters to me is that
if you have the ability to pledge,
I'm trying to do so over a longterm
period because the patrion is really my
salary.
So knowing what I'm going to get gives
me the ability to plan new projects,
bigger projects in the future.
It just makes everything a lot more
stable.
So I'd rather you do a dollar,
you know,
over a year,
then,
you know,
$5 or $10 over a couple of weeks.
Obviously if you can do $5 over a year,
you're amazing and I can't even believe
it.
Um,
but thank you guys for everything you've
donated to this channel.
It's been amazing.
It's helped me grow this thing and it's
growing really fast now and it's a
really exciting.
People are watching and paying
attention,
which is all I ever wanted to start.
So thank you again.
I will see you guys next Wednesday.